welcome to the first
project camp update video uh so these
videos are basically just to
keep progress of what we're doing to
make sure we archive it for ourselves
and also for our family and friends to
follow because we basically bought this
big piece of land in portugal
and going to transform it into something
to live and work in a more sustainable
way
we don't really know where this is going
we have some sort of wild plans in our
hat
but i guess this is just to keep
following that
process so if you're interested make
sure to subscribe if not
yeah don't overall the videos are going
to be very quick and rough
because we just want to make sure we
actually
do document it and don't forget about it
uh so if you make it too complex i know
we're not gonna do it in the end
and we just have very little people
around here so we need to use our
resources properly
so yeah first update let me give you a
quick tour of the land
[Music]
so we're now walking down on the land so
this is all the land
and above there as well actually but
there's a bit less
interesting things to show for now
and this road is going down to the
workspace and the kitchen
we're first gonna have a look at the
workspace
which is a bit hidden in the bushes
around here on the left
yes so we can go in here
a very good pathway
so here's the building
and the workspace was all burned down
during a fire a few years ago
so the roof is pretty yeah broken
and slowly the trees are taking over
it's a pretty big space all the way down
there
some concrete structure i don't know how
strong or solid it is i guess we have to
test
looks like there's some work to do
so yeah that's uh the current workspace
but we can go in as well
because yesterday i made a little
pathway
which yeah it's kind of fun there's a
lot of overgrown bushes
so mainly thorns so you really have to
make your way in
and but again it could be fun together
so here's the front side of the
workspace so we made a
hole there well the hole was there we
just cleaned it
and then here through the thorns made a
bit of a pot
oh yeah and the camera sometimes has a
bit of focusing issues
okay so right there
is another entrance
so yeah as you can see it's fully grown
but this is the structure
here's another part i didn't think it
ever had a roof
but it does have a foundation there
so i think you know i'll do a scenario
this is all just workspace
and then here the roof i guess i need to
watch out that those things don't fall
on my head
should be okay otherwise we'll do it
like this at least then we have it on
camera
which could be a cool shot maybe next
time
and then here's our little pull out
so yeah that's the workspace still
some work to do
uh i think this could be a very cool
place because
down there well you don't really see it
now you have some you could have a nice
view
so now we go up to the other structure
which is going to be the kitchen so we
go up here
through bushes and these are basically
the two existing structures on the land
and i would say they're not very well
built
but yeah so we have to see if we can
renovate them
or we have to rebuild them
so that could be the kitchen also a lot
of thorns here
we also made a pathway here here
and as you can see underneath there's
really ruins so they've been built like
over 50 years ago
and this is more built later on top
but underneath this could be a super
cool place
to store food because of the thick rocks
the granite it keeps everything very
cool
i mean you could use some cleaning up
but
and there's another area here
looks lighter on the camera
yeah so that's
the downside
and then the top i actually never
entered even before
we bought it because you just couldn't
get in or at least not quickly when
with the people there so started making
a pathway as well
in here in the forest it's not really a
forest
starting forest
so a lot of this was burned down a few
years ago with a big fire
so that's why you see a lot of young
trees now
there's actually a lot of cashy trees
which grow super fast but in a way they
also kind of dominate
all the other trees so in a way it's
cool that they're there
but maybe for the long term not really
but we still need to learn more about
that
but i was quite surprised when going
into this kitchen
because i mean it's also
a very rough building almost
falling apart but this actually could be
very nice i think
i don't know what this flap is some
insulation material
put into the wall i don't know
but
yeah so here could be a nice way to cook
so imagine
imagine over here you have a little
kitchen chop chop chop
something in the fridge
could be nice to cook and then what i
like about this
is this window here
because it really gives you an overview
of the land where you could grow
your vegetables which i think is a nice
addition
uh yeah so that was the kitchen
structure
ah still not the shot and
let's see now we can oops sorry cart was
full
um yeah now we're going back from the
kitchen
towards uh a bit more down
just to show you the end of the land
yeah like i said very bushy
all right so i have a walk on here but
maybe i'll just take a run
trump
so yeah this is the bottom there's the
kitchen quite a big piece of land
that's i guess the downside of a big
land you need to run around
a lot to go from eight to b um
and currently we are parked
down here at the bottom so basically
everything here is the land
hola that's the neighbor portuguese
no english i still need to turn some
portuguese
so that's currently the house
yeah and this is the bottom of the land
but i realized actually forgot a few
things
but maybe i could just so over here we
have an electricity pool
i mean was already there to provide the
neighbors more electricity
need to get it at some point as well
but i figured you can climb in there a
bit
and you might have a better view
it's getting a bit narrower for the
shoes so stop here
you can see a little bit the
surroundings
overall it's very green
maybe next time we go higher
all right let's go to another thing this
area
at the end is probably where we're going
to set up the base camp in the beginning
because it's kind of flat
and protected so this means the two
shipping containers would come here
um where you can see more about that the
next time
well one thing i wanted to show you is
that
the neighbors were actually saying there
used to be a well
up here in the bushes
where that had enough water all year
round
to provide the land with water which is
kind of cool to have
but we also never saw that one before
because it was just covered in bushes
so yeah i did some
chopping and some
walking in the bushes
then i made a pathway i'm just looking
where i was
all right sorry i had to turn off my
camera for a bit because i got a bit
confused uh
this whole bush here which was an
upcoming forest was chopped down
so i was calling a bit to see why
looks pretty rough yeah because this
wasn't here
like yesterday but apparently someone in
the neighborhood
chops down trees here for his firewood
uh yeah wasn't really aware of that
it looks pretty rough i mean change is
kind of the landscape
but i guess we need to work out a little
bit these things as well
with the neighborhood here on the land
[Music]
yeah anyway let's have a look at the
water
i guess now i also lost my pathway
somewhere here
but it doesn't have that many storage
so maybe we can just go in here
there's also a lot of um mushrooms in
here at this moment
that's good still need to learn which
one you can eat here
today and then somewhere
i think it's there
so here's the water
let me take a batter
sorry for the sound effects
so here's quite a big pile of water
it's a bit covered between all the other
things
let me throw a stick yeah water
but i just need some cleaning up before
we can even access it
all right so that was it the first
project camp update video
if you want to see more project camp
videos make sure to visit our academy
and if you want to continue to follow
this process and see what we're going to
do with the land
make sure to subscribe there are a lot
of videos
and updates coming up to see how we
regenerate the land and how we set up
our infrastructure
and if you want to help out in some way
make sure to visit
support.projectcamp.com
to see how you can help out at this
moment thanks for watching and see you
in the next video